work work work you can't build a
reputation on what you're going to do
sure you get it you know that you're
eventually gonna have to get to work and
that work might be quite difficult maybe
you think you already started but do you
really understand do you have any idea
just how much work there is going to be
not work until you get your big break
not work until you make a name for
yourself but work work work forever and
ever
is it ten thousand hours and twenty
thousand hours to mastery the answer is
it doesn't matter
there is no end zone so think of a
number is to live in a conditional
future we're simply talking about a lot
of hours than to get where we want to go
isn't about brilliance but continual
effort that's the reality how we respond
to challenge and where we decide to put
our energy decides what will ultimately
accomplish as a young basketball player
Bill Bradley will remind himself when
you are not practicing remember someone
somewhere is practicing and when you
meet him he will win the Bible says
something similar in its own way blessed
are those servants whom the master finds
awake when you come
you can lie to yourself saying that you
put into the time or pretend that you're
working but eventually someone will show
up you'll be tested and quite possibly
found out since Bradley went on to be an
all-american a Rhodes Scholar than a
two-time champion with the New York
Knicks and a u.s. senator you get the
sense of this sort of dedication take
you places so we must have it because
there is no triumph without toil world
is finding yourself alone to the track
when the weather kept everyone else
indoors work is pushing through the pain
and crappy first drafts of prototypes it
is ignoring whatever plaudits others are
getting and more importantly ignoring
whatever products you may be getting
because there is work to be done work
doesn't want to be good it is made so
despite the head work if you need to
feel confident or prior to anything take
it in here
there is another old expression you know
a work win by the chips they leave it's
true to judge your progress properly
just take a look at the floor the
heights by great men reached and kept
were not attained by sudden flight but
they well their competition slept well
toriel aboard in the night Henry
Wadsworth Longfellow